Folks.
It ain't about that.
It ain't about the guy who tries buying a clean car.
When you are dirty.
It's not his fault.
It's you should figure out how to be clean.
You should figure out how to do a job that doesn't involve you walking in mud
all day and that's possible because somebody else has done it.
I don't buy the idea that you know the society the way it is right now.
It has to be this way.
Someone's always going to have to work at Burger King.
Someone's always going to have to,
I don't buy that.
I think people are pretty fucking flexible.
If you look at the broad spectrum of humans and human behavior from different
cultures all over the world,
it's pretty obvious to me that there's,
there's a lot of different ways that people can act.
We don't have to have fast food workers.
We don't,
we don't have to have people who work shit jobs.
We don't have to.
We just need to figure out how to restructure society so everybody somehow or
another plays apart cause something to contribute,
something to share.
I mean,
that's what a real society is supposed to be like,
I've give you some coconuts,
you give me some fish,
you know,
we make a deal and you do it back and forth and left and right.
And when there's nothing to contribute,
then you start looking or present needs to give us jobs.
We need jobs.
So instead of something to contribute,
just find something to do with your time.
And then it becomes about doing that more than it becomes about finding
something to contribute.
So society gets wrapped around becoming a part of a machine society instead of
becoming a bunch of individuals that are expressing themselves in unique ways
and everybody's sort of borrows and shares and sells this and you sell that.
And we all sort of figure out how we can contribute in a society.
We got sidetracked and diverted into these boxes that they call companies and
corporations and we got stuck into these containers.
They go Cuba offices and we've got forced into this system.
So our time,
instead of it being invested in making pottery or,
or fixing cars or doing something where you have a passion or you have some sort
of a connection to,
instead of that,
you've sold your life to sit in a box and worked for a machine,
an uncaring machine that demands productivity,
doesn't understand you.
It doesn't want to understand you.
It has a bunch of very strict things in order to keep the humor at a minimum in
the office,
just in case one,
he fuckheads says some stupid sex jokes that gets them sued and you have to give
somebody $1 million.
So get it together.
And this is your life now.
No natural behavior.
Everybody's wearing clothes.
They don't want to,
where everybody is showing up and doing something they don't want to do,
they have no connection to.
That's the problem with our society.
And then what's the reward for all this stuff?
Go home,
get a big TV,
go home.
You're going to get a shiny belt buckle.
You're going to get a nice purse.
You're gonna wear shoes that you couldn't afford last week.
You're going to get that dream car and every week we're chasing down this new
object and every week we're trying to fill this hole in this,
this,
this sad shadow of a life that we've been left with after work that you work
eight to whatever to hours a day plus commuting and then you'll like this
and that's your life.
That's your real fucking life.
All that other stuff is not your life anymore.
All that other stuff is work.
And most of us have committed to that.
I know you've been there before and I've been there before and we understand
that it's trapped because we got out of it.
But for the people that are in it,
a lot of times they don't even understand it's a trap.
They just think it's a good job.
They think they got dental,
I'm doing really good and I got my own parking spots,
got my name on it,
and you're just a piece of a heartless shitty machine that makes money.
But don't you think you'd have to go through all that just to figure out what
you want to do?
Because,
I mean,
I didn't think I did,
but I don't think you have to look.
I,
I did,
but I became what I became a comedian when I was 21 I was 100% convinced that I
was going to be a stand up comedian for the rest of my life.
Like I didn't need the worry about what was next.
I was like,
oh,
this is what I'm doing.
Like I'm this,
no,
I don't want to do anything else like this.
This is what I'm doing.
Once I found it,
I was good.
All the jobs were just to feed myself while I was trying to make that work.
But it's,
um,
to get one and commit to it and have it become a part of your life becomes
really problematic because if you're a viewer,
a dirt bag like myself who drove limos and did construction and they always,
you know,
almost kind of temporary jobs and a lot of people drift in and out of,
there was nothing expected of you.
But if you get hired by a major corporation,
become a big part of their,
their,
you know,
their program.
Like let's say you're also an animator and you get a Gig.
Like I have a friend who,
uh,
was,
an illustrator and he was working for Nickelodeon and he got fired and he was
panicking and he was like,
shit,
I don't know what the fuck to do.
He's like,
ah,
you know,
I gotta I gotta figure out another job.
So he started making paintings and selling his paintings.
It was the greatest thing that's ever happened to him.
Now he's just super,
his name is Todd white.
He's a super successful artist.
He makes like this,
uh,
kind of Martini style.
Like a cocktail was from the like,
like cocktail parties when the 1920s,
like those cool kind of cartoonish Martini glass things.
He's got a real specific,
distinctive style.
It's really cool.
These are great artists and he's also a black belt in Jujitsu.
I know him from a John Joc Machado's.
He's a great guy,
but it was an opportunity for him to,
to lose a job and even a job that he loved as an illustrator.
But you know,
I'm sure you'd much rather do what he wants to do and do what's going on in his
mind.
And let's go down.
Oh,
he's really cool.
He's bad ass and he's a great guy too.
Very cool guy.